لذا فقط من هو إذا حصلنا على أي بريجوسيان
وما الذي نعرفه عن قائد
شركة فاغنر العسكرية الخاصة جيدًا
للإجابة على ذلك دعونا نجلب
قدرات CNN المثبتة في لندن حتى
تساعدنا سلمى في فهم اللاعبين المشاركين
في جانب فاغنر هنا
نعم إيفان  لقد كان التقدم في يوم من الأيام هو
السلاح السري للرئيس بوتين وهو الآن
شوكة في خاصرته إلى حد كبير، فقد جاء من
نفس البدايات المتواضعة للرئيس
بوتين في سانت بطرسبرغ، وكان يعرفه
منذ التسعينيات، وقد بنى
إمبراطورية تقدم الطعام، إمبراطورية أدت إلى ذلك أه
الاسم المستعار بوتين  طاهٍ ولكن كان ذلك بالفعل في
غزو شبه جزيرة القرم في عام 2014 عندما
بدأ في الصعود إلى الصدارة كرئيس
لمجموعة فاغنر العسكرية، ثم
استخدم تلك المجموعة بشكل أساسي
كجيش بوتين الخاص الذي ينفذ أوامره في
أفريقيا والشرق الأوسط ولكن كل ذلك  لقد تم ذلك
خلف ستار دون أن
يدعي إيفجيني بيركوسيان أي الفضل على الإطلاق، ولم
يكن الأمر كذلك إلا بعد أن جاء غزو أوكرانيا
عندما صعد بالفعل إلى
دائرة الضوء وقام بذلك بصوت عالٍ وبأقصى قدر ممكن من
العدائية حيث
ظهر الجيش الروسي على
الخطوط الأمامية.  في أوكرانيا، مرارًا وتكرارًا،
ينادي
تيري بقيادة الجيش الروسي، مما يؤدي إلى بدء
حرب كلامية مع وزير الدفاع
الروسي قائلاً إنه يجب محاكمته
لأنه خذل شعبه وفي هذه
الرسائل، وأنا أعلم أنك تلعب
بعضها بشكل صحيح.  الآن هو لا يتحدث فقط
مع رجاله إلى مجموعة المرتزقة الخاصة به، بل
كان يتحدث إلى
الجمهور الروسي بشكل عام، ولهذا السبب
طرح الكثيرون منذ أشهر السؤال لماذا
سمح الرئيس بوتين لهذا الرجل ليس
فقط بالارتقاء إلى مستوى بارز
ولكن للارتقاء إلى مستوى المعارضة إذا
قمتم بنشر غسيل روسيا القذر
على تلك الخطوط الأمامية، فلدينا إجابة
إذا صح التعبير الآن مع بيان الرئيس بوتين
اليوم الذي اتهمكم
بأي تقدم بالخيانة، وقال إنه
سيحاسب كما أنتم.  تم ذكره ولكن
هل فات الأوان لاحتواء رجل
يقول الآن أن لديه
25000 جندي و25000 مرتزق مسلحين
ومستعدين للدفاع عنه الذي
يسيطر على مدينة في الجزء الجنوبي من
القيادة العسكرية للجنوب في
روسيا، وهذا أمر ضخم  والتحدي المعقد
للرئيس بوتين وهو
يحدث أمام
أعين الجميع، نعم، العالم كله
يشاهد أم
سلمى، قد يكون من الصعب التنبؤ في
هذه المرحلة ولكن ما يمكن أن يكون
مصير بريغوسي هنا
من الصعب للغاية التنبؤ به، أعني أن
هذا هو  وضع غير مسبوق
استحضر الرئيس بوتين نفسه تاريخًا
يعود تاريخه إلى أكثر من مائة عام عندما
تحدث عن هذا الوضع وشبهه بالتمرد
والانقلاب ومحاولة
الإطاحة بسلطة روسيا، مما
يعني أنه يجب عليه بالتأكيد الرد
بالقوة، ولكن مرة أخرى كيف تبدو تلك القوة؟
عندما يكون لديك
تقدم يصمد مرة أخرى في روستوف
مع جنوده ورجاله المستعدين
للدفاع عنه، يقول وكيف
يلجأ الرئيس بوتين الآن إلى
الجيش الروسي وأولئك القادة العسكريين الكبار
الذين سمح
باستعداءهم وإذلالهم علنًا من قبل
باغوسيان  لعدة أشهر دون أن يبدو
ضعيفًا دون أن يكون مدينًا لهم
بذلك في الأيام المقبلة، الأمر الأكثر
إثارة للقلق أعتقد بالطبع هو أن
احتمال حدوث هذا
التحول الدموي في التقدم يبدو كل شيء في أنه تم
تصنيفه بالفعل عبر الحدود ودخل
الأراضي الروسية وسيطر على
المدينة  وقال إنه على استعداد لفعل
أي شيء للدفاع عن نفسه في مجموعته،
هل الجيش الروسي على استعداد لفعل
الشيء نفسه؟ لا يمكن للمرء إلا أن يفترض ذلك، وبالنظر إلى
كلمات الرئيس بوتين القوية جدًا، فهل
هذا يعني أن الروس يقاتلون الروس على
الأراضي الروسية في الأيام المقبلة، كل
هذا  بالطبع، يتم دفع الحرب الأوكرانية إلى
الخلفية عندما نتحدث عن
الرئيس بوتين الذي يحاول ببساطة الدفاع عن
عرشه